In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 1st, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Remedios, Bishop of Reims and Apostle to the Franks.
The birth of Saint Remedios in the year 438 was foretold to his aged parents by a Holy
Hermit called Montanos.
From childhood, the noble youth devoted himself to the acquisition of secular and sacred learning,
and then withdrew to a little house near Laon, where he led an exemplary life of holy
solitude.
When the Sea of Reims became vacant, the clergy and people resorted to his retreat and
carried him off as their bishop elect, in spite of his being only 22 years of age.
At the time of his consecration, his brow shone with light and was scented with a heavenly
perfume.
Of all the notable men of Flanders and northern Gaul, the young bishop soon became the
most renowned.
Higgins were converted and Aryan heretics brought to repentance through his ardent preaching.
He established dioceses, set up parishes, and inspired the inhabitants of districts recently
devastated by barbarian raids, with love for enemies, detachment, and a longing for the
good things of the world to come.
Everywhere he preached, the truth of his words was confirmed by miracles.
When he ate, the birds came to take their food from his hands.
He healed the sick, delivered those possessed by evil spirits, and once, when the city was
on fire, he threw himself into the flames, and drove them back.
During the years when the Roman West was in agony through the invasions of barbarian peoples,
the Visigoth and Burgundian adherents of Aryanism occupied the south of Gaul, the Alemani occupied
the banks of the Rhine, and the Franks who were still pagan the north of Gaul.
On the death of his father Hildedik, in the year 482, Clovis, who was only 15, became the
leader of the rough Frankish warriors.
Although he was still an idolater, he admired the monks and had a great respect for the orthodox
bishops, especially Saint Remedios, whose sound advice he followed.
In the year 493, he married Saint Clotilde, who also influenced him for the good.
As his army was retreating before the Alemani, Clovis turned to the god of Clotilde and Remedios,
and won a brilliant victory at Tolbiac.
God's answer to his prayer made him decide to become a Christian, and he asked Saint Remedios
to instruct him in the rudiments of the faith.
As he listened to the bishop describing all that had happened to Christ in his passion,
the great-hearted warrior exclaimed,
Oh, if only I had been there with my Franks to set him free.
Two years later, he summoned all the magnates of his realm and from beyond its borders to
come to Reims for his baptism.
On the eve of that day, Saint Remedios had the king and his retinue come into the church,
where in powerful words he set before them the worthlessness of false gods, and the great
mysteries of the Christian faith.
All at once a heavenly light and fragrance filled the church, and they heard a voice from
on high that said, Peace be with you.
As he immersed him in the waters of the new birth, Remedios said to the king,
Bow your head, proud sicumber, worship what you have burnt, and burn what you have worshipped.
But when the moment came for anointing the newly baptized king with holy chrism,
the bishop saw that it was lacking, raising his eyes to heaven, he implored God to provide it,
whereupon a white dove came down from heaven with a vile of miraculous oil.
Two of the king's sisters and three thousand of his lords and warriors were baptized at the same time
as Glovis. This event was decisive for the conversion of the Franks and for the birth of France
as a Christian nation. With the spiritual guidance of Saint Remedios,
Glovis, like a second constantine, sought in the years that followed to bring together the barbarian
newcomers and the Romanized inhabitants of Gaul and to confirm his people in the true faith.
In his old age, Saint Remedios went blind, but steadfast in prayer and hope he miraculously recovered
his sight, a served the divine liturgy for a last time and fell asleep in peace in the year 533.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.